Tom is next up Tom's in Atlanta Georgia
hey Tom welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
thanks Dave
so tell me what your net worth is sir
just try it's a million dollars of two
million yes okay and how old are you sir
sixty-five cool and what is that money
invested in the the investment portion
portion is in growth stock mutual funds
okay and what else is it in real estate
the home is the paid off mortgage and
just the personal holdings
so mutual funds in your house okay and
what's your home worth how about three
and a half okay all right cool
very cool and what was your average
income through your working lifetime sir
well I got out of the Navy in the
submarine service it was $6.75 an hour
and when I pretty much retired although
I do still do some work it was just a
little shy of 200,000 okay cool how long
were you in the Navy seven years thank
you for your service
I appreciate that what do you do for a
living after the Navy was a 200k I went
from I was a naval nuclear submarine
operator and I went into commercial
nuclear power and I was a with nuclear
utilities that followed by companies his
specialty mate and so on nuclear power
plants very cool
that's fun good for you excellent Clara
but excellent do a lot of good people
there yeah excellent career path I love
it
okay and so did you inherit money you
were your wife my wife's father passed
away we inherited a small amount of
money was allowed us to pay off the
mortgage on the house although we had a
very small mortgage at that time but
2012 we paid off the mortgage which was
other than the mortgage that mortgage
you know I wish it was about a hundred
thousand dollars okay one hundred ninety
dollars a month okay so you inherited
100k but it was by then you were already
worth over a million yes absolutely
yeah and mutual funds and your 401ks I
guess and that kind of enough right yeah
we we were pretty diligent about
November 81 was the first time we could
contribute to a 401k and we just worked
their butt off to every raise we got
just mashed it out and we just helped it
at Max's for long as we could cool how
much debt other than your home have you
used in the past for presently presently
not we have no debt whatsoever how long
have you been debt free I would say
we've been debt free for since probably
the mid 1990s 90 I mean probably after
my daughter's wedding after that we paid
that off after her college tuition
probably 1997-1998 we had no debt and
other than the mortgage can since you
were like 40 years old yes sir that's
about true okay very cool all right cool
how many new cars have you bought uh
over the course of our marriage through
married 44 years but over the course a
couple but most of the time driving back
and forth to work I Drive pretty much
beaters we pleasantly drive at 2010 in
the vehicle that's got a hundred and one
thousand miles on it
Wow so what do you tell a 25 year old
that's listening to us right now
401k max it every time you get a raised
mastic don't use credit you know my
mother used the envelope system when I
was six years old but you know I like
the idea I know I know the idea of
paying cash and the of not using credit
and it just live within your means and
as much as you can that's it it's just
there's just not anything like magical
about this you don't have to invent
Microsoft do you know there's no magic
about it it's all pretty pretty simple
you know it's it's you grind it out over
a period of years so you were probably
worth a million dollars by the time you
were 55 yes that's that's true or a
little bit before okay your first were
your first million all right so what
part does generosity you're giving play
in this process throughout your life you
know a couple things I was I was
listening to the show before the call
and we've done a lot of things for the
our kids and grandkids to give them
opportunities that they would not have
had before the other thing we like to do
is we my wife I love to go out to dinner
and find a young couple or middle
very couple and just comped their dinner
without them ever knowing and just let
them look around and wonder where they
where the money came from that's kind of
been kind of fun
that's fun I do like doing that that's a
blast that's absolutely fine so what you
pay for your most expensive pair of blue
jeans in your life well I can remember
my mom giving me a $10 bill and going
three actress or in Southern California
and paying ten bucks there's not a lot I
mean Wrangler Levi's are fine for me
while I wear blue jeans there you go all
right
and I got a picture of you showing up
here on the TV on a pretty nice bike
what is it a Harley
that's a Harley after the 1998 95th
anniversary edition Harley
so wheat you earned that baby that's a
great that was my that was my one
indulgence that's a pretty nice one
that's a great one well done sir well
thank you hey thanks for sharing your
story in your life with us your great
American success story I'm proud to know
you
thanks Dave appreciate your show have a
good day
you